I forgot my shirt went live, eeps, eepsie
good morning, good evening, good afternoon little reflens, you see me?
okay I know we're on the just chatting screen okay, I know we're not on the game screen
and you're probably shitting your pantelones okay, but we have an absolute fantastic update
which I can't talk about, I'm allowed to talk about it now okay, Viallure officially
have partnered with gamersupps, eepie, all the girls' descriptions will be updated and
they'll be tweets made very shortly, but Viallure are officially partnered with gamersupps
you can use everyone's name as a checkout code for 10% off, I'm not even trolling, yes
they really happened, I don't know how it happened, but it happened, gamersupps thumbs
up, we love gamersupps, as always the girls get to keep 100% of the earnings, Viallure
do not touch it because I don't want to touch it okay, I finally can buy strongy's sweat
well apparently there's a flavour called Isaac Tears which is so awesome, Viallure's
descriptions will get updated soon, there will be tweets made very shortly, what is
that?
it is an energy drinks company, but you can also get non-caffeinated beverages as well,
but yeah it's another income source for the girlies and I'm so happy, but yeah that was
my big news that was kind of like lurking around in the background, I got a new short
that got uploaded as well, I'm just reading some of the comments on it, strongy is neurodivergent
if that's true base, at one point screams I'm freaking normal, now you can get a taste
of mummy, I mean after the last run it was obvious you're the final gamer, that's why
they wanted a piece of me, blame the tism, yep blame the tism, but yes I have a new short
if you haven't seen it yet, it's about how the background musics are all about sonic
heroes which actually came in really good timing because we literally just played sonic
heroes, sonic heroes, I will definitely do an endurance, it's some comment, oh I thought
this is about how the veiler company was being made up of lootubers was the exposing, I didn't
know it was going to be about background music plagiarising, my guys not that serious, it's
not called plagiarism, it's called influence, have you heard of influence before? I've
approved the comment anyway but what the fuck it's not actually really exposing the fucking
company what the fuck, I also had an offline tip so thank you spidey for the offline tip,
they put tess for some reason, I don't know why, Mr Beast collab when? Mr, Mr, Mr Beast,
oh but speaking of things that are coming up soon, now this one's just coming up for
me and it was you coming up for me, hey let's go we got an update, check it out, I'm poignant
with you, look at your little little, I like how you've already somehow got the nicotine
patch on your head, I'm leaving it because it's true to your design, but check us out
together, we're so cute, so we've got this version that's coming along very quickly,
the artist is working so hard and diligently, that's version one which is like a full, that's
like the line art if you will, and then we've got Colored in Tommy, Colored in Tommy me,
I'm so cute, but we're gonna have like an x-ray shot so I'm about to be able to do the see-through
view of you and my tum tum and then I have some cursed ASMR to record, I actually came up with a
new meme ASMR and it's absolutely horrifying, wait I might be able to find it in my notes because
I wrote it down, Scottish e-girl Miaw is like a cat for money ASMR, I know that sounds really weird
out of context, I have a picture to go with it okay, and it's basically like you're my sugar daddy
but I'm Scottish, so you're like Miaw for me and I'm like I'm not gonna Miaw for you and it's like
do you need the money and I'm like I guess, I'll mention like the steam summer sales which are
finishing today by the way if you haven't picked up any games on steam summer sales do it, and that's
the only reason we're on the screen okay, where's my game, where's my game, are you squidding me
right now, where my game, I broke my game, wait you guys can celebrate memberships now, one month
memberships, oh it's been a month of memberships, she finally got some sleep as a here's the first
month of membership, thank you pentane one, I can't believe it's freaking me, are you squidding
me right now, oh I see gen two is on the way, congrats on the new addition to the family,
are you squidding me right now, wait what leaks are going on, hold on a minute
thank you, wait I can see new member on stream elements, does it only work if it's a thingy,
oh my god, are you squidding me right now, oh my god you can do it, oh my gosh, right this game's
about us by the way, thank you so much KfE Spidey Imperial Monarch Cookie Fumbler, is Brian reading
out your messages, he's not, I need to enable TTS on Brian like reader, oh that's so crazy it's been
a month of monetization, I am here for this game and strongy commenting on it, so this game had
everyone in a freaking chokehold, oh my god it's just a sea of green, yeah, I pour black blood
aqua boy, oh does why is Brian not reading any of it, reluctantly saying li li li li li li, oh my
god it's only Dean, I don't know if I can keep on refilling me right now, you've got too much stamina
for me, I'm just woken up, you need to go easy on me, okay Brian's definitely not reading that,
okay I'll just read it don't worry, Imperial Monarch Cereblates, one month of membership, one ahead,
oh one already, it's really been a fun time with you, love love love love love love love,
free super day, hi mom, hi we play, so love love love, one month of top tier content, are you joking
me, yesterday's stream was awful, I could not formulate sentences, oh my god, I would like start a sentence
and then like swap to something else and I don't even know how I did it, a glorious month of membership
actual free super chat for real, are you screaming, keep doing what you've been doing,
refilling love, hi riz, one month down, many more to go, I was going one more to go, I was like damn,
thank you, thank you very much, hello strongy, hello refling, I want the two-year badge, you
love the color, the perilous and on it, oh that's right your little shells are blue now,
oh zarian, it's been a month strongy, love love love, Rico, here's two many more months,
sleepy phoenix, love ya, be a lord love, grumble, one month already, it feels like it's just been
yesterday, shoot up, time goes fast, you and nightingale, one month already, hate for the rest to come,
wow, there's another one of this game, well I looked into the sentence to censor it in case there
was anything that there shouldn't be but I didn't really look like that, um giving kitsune, thanks
for the funny stream, every moment has been made in the love you strongy, oh I love you too love
replay, ruin desolation, oh wow it's already been a month, time flies with the people you love,
oh replay, I love you too, stop being so nice to me, you're gonna, you try and make me melt,
I am like sugar, I'm from Germany, you are not made of sugar, you can go and walk in the rain,
it will not perish you, tiny spiny, team chaotic, the detectives that you want on your side, team
chaotic, the detectives tracking down your crime, wait did they have a motto like that, there's honey
pop from the same devs, yes, I think honey pop is the puzzle one but I didn't want to play the puzzle
one, I wanted to play veal or simulator because originally I was gonna play idle manager but
apparently it's super hard, dragon dread again karma, what glorious month fellow leafling
with many more to come, oh yeah I'm not the only one to come, milk kadmus, one blessed month with
mummy, here's many more, thank you, no alessandro, congrats stroney, thank you, thank you, thank you
leafling, inner wit, thanks for everything mome, looking forward to the next 30 years of streams,
would you still watch me if I was a girl streamer, not even a hag, will surpass hag by then,
would you watch me if I was a girl streamer, pretty please, will you watch my running commentary
on our yearly playthrough of camryo and picking up the fruits on one go, asterix love, sure yeah
background music still on, you're absolutely correct leafling, thank goodness you got that
cause I certainly would not have if I didn't read that comment, viral momello, are you squidding me
right now, Scottish gilf let's go, heck yeah, okay let's play it, so this game came out and
everyone was in a freaking chokehold over it, I'm not really sure I'd watch you even if I were one,
okay, what's the point of living without watching mommy play childhood games, I was watching this
then streamer do, are you squidding me right now, like a media share thing, prosdino, ever since
violers debut, I've slept less than, oh well, we might be on the same page, I'm gonna be honest
leafling, but I also feel a lot more energized so it cancels it out, thanks mommy, hi you're welcome,
I had a big sleep, I slept for like seven hours after stream and then I've just slept for, I want
to say five hours there, so I'm gonna slurp my tea, hold on, oh no I've just accepted, the stream's
gonna be, they're limited ads, it's fine, yearly cameo placer, I'd be really down for it, like I
just, I'll eat cameo, I'm sorry, it's like such a good game, you can wrap it up, or wrap it up,
seven hours is a big sleep, well it is in consideration that I had two hours the previous day,
are you squidding me right now, oh soul insert, coming out with the lore, actually I remember
honeycam studio came out with negative reception, because of the different art style and lack of
scenes, I'd buy veal or something, I considered it, I considered producing a vn at one point,
because they're a lot cheaper than the average game, it might officially be the first game I'd
produce, I would not base it after the veal or girls just because you never know what will happen,
you know I might do something catastrophic, although I did say to the girls if I ever do
anything bad take me around back and shoot me, do not ever let me live long enough to become the bad
guy, and they were all giggling, but I don't think they realised how serious that was, I was like
take me out back and shoot me, do not let me be the bad guy, okay, do not ever let me act like
you know the very thing I swore to destroy, don't let me be great, as I said we've got
gamersups codes, our updates will all be updated soon, there'll be graphics added to stream soon,
and there'll be tweets about it as well, they are so kind to getting that organised,
but as always the girls get to keep 100% of what they earned through that code,
veal or don't touch it, go straight to their accounts, they will attest to this because
I'm about to have to get them to sort out their accounts, what are you playing, don't look okay,
don't look, recon crusader, love you goddess, love you replaying,
but yes the girls have gamersups accounts, if you wanted to activate the code right now,
just use the code and then their name, if you literally mersey, we everyone got their first
name, so strony, mersey, azura, emmy, ac, mersey, asad mersey, you're gonna miss him,
ac, emmy, azura, shibi, mersey, strony, oh I'll go everyone, okay, I was like hold on a minute
something, I don't know, sassapress, one month ago I fell in love with you and I predict that for
the foreseeable future I shall be in love with you, here's to many more months mommy, I just added
that myself as a thank you for falling in love, get plapped, get plapped, get plapped,
could you imagine an azura waifu cup, unfortunately I'm not sure how gamersups works,
I will ask permission to see if I'm allowed to discuss certain things but at this moment in time,
I'm a good girl, gamersups pog, so if you ever wanted to try gamersups, I'm actually gonna make a
handcam ASMR video about them because they are very kind and they're willing to send out PR packages
so I get to ASMR muck about with their products, so that'll be fun, zero thank you for the one
month, love you mommy, congrats on everything on this one month, can't wait to spend more time with
you, let's go! Just so you know, aside from the main theme, all four teams from Sonic Heroes
have a theme song, we can for Team Sonic, this machine for Team Dark, follow me for Team Rose
and Team Chaotix for Team Chaotix, listen to them all, they're bangers, oh yeah that took me by
surprise when we were playing against Team Rose, my voice is absolutely correct otherwise so thank
you tiny spainy for the tip, yeah I got so surprised, I started hearing, I was like lyrics
and songs in this game, I wonder what mommy's flavor would be, probably pish, no no one's gonna
buy pish, um we will play every team so listen to everything, yes I will ask, um, gamersups what
kind of insider stuff I can mention because it's nothing to do with me so for once I can't even
be transparent, something behavior, hey thank you zero, I don't actually think I said your name when
I said that, peeler flavor, I mean, I mean, Chaotix theme is the banger, I see an enemy would have
a pish, right okay, user done, let me finish this team, we'll get into this game, um so this is
Honey Cam Studios, this is a, uh, simulator strategy building game, I am so bad at identifying
game types, I'm not even kidding, I am absolutely rotten at it, it's fucking mean, I have absolutely
no idea how to categorize games, I mean you guys were literally telling me what, oh I've already
forgotten the name, the type roguelike and roguelike are like two different things, it's a tycoon
a management sim, okay, okay, yeah, for some reason I need to do like a video essay on
categorizations of gaming's because I'm just absolutely awful, gamer slob sex vealer is the
only way to pheromone max taken out, this is literally a game of you running a virtual version of
Exactly, is this game about us? Okay, now I remember when this game had a choke
haul on everyone, choke hold on everyone, but I never played it because I was very young when
it came out and I was still at the mercy of like asking my mum to buy me games, smile, because steam
games and I never really had the money for it and just call it drinking, eat me, I'm in
the strong need to put me in a choke hold on, honeycam falls under the sim, simulation
and management categories not to be confused, stimulation, get it, yep, yeah you get it, okay,
I'm sure you want to start a new fair, let's go, yeah, there I am,
hold on, let me pop this
yeah vealer did exist, finally it took a year but we got here in the end, is this loading now?
show up even later next time, that'd be sweet, that'd be sweet, I love her already,
I chuckled at someone, yeah damn straight you did, that's because you're delirious you're laughing
at my jokes, why did she sound like Emmy, a little loader, hold on can I, oh I have just
how'd that make it go big again, is it control shift or something, no I'm skipping the dialogue,
I accidentally made it not full screen, oh for fuck's sake, how did I keep doing this,
hold on this is terrible, how did I make it big, help me make it big, roof laying please,
how did I make it big again, I accidentally minimized it but it's like locked and it won't make me
let it go big, all enter, no, what are you doing video game, can I stretch it without it being
stretched, okay, that's just gonna have to do this, oh stop it, I mean let's keep it 100 here,
this is the closest you're gonna, I will edit the sentence once we get in here,
so I'll put the music down but I'll put the voices up, I mean let's keep it 100 here,
this is the closest we're gonna get to female interaction right, whoa stereo and man's just
entered the fucking game and we're getting insulted, hold on a minute, hello, why are we being
insulted, help me make it big, if you put it in a choke hold it'll become big, roasting speed run,
should be payment enough and it will be since that's the only payment you're getting,
to touch women, let's not waste any more time, I'll start you out with one of our fresh prospects,
which one of these girls catches your eye, okay okay okay let's go let's go let's go,
this is where taste comes in, teen and fit, big nonga nongas and glasses,
Latina, oh it's between Tiffany and Kiana,
you know da, what kind of mood are we in today, do we want kawaii ne or do we want la chancla,
do we want beaten up by, I love Latina's sonic, wait why did you say sonic at the end of I love
Latina's, does sonic love Latina's, I'm kind of, I don't know, I feel like Tiffany's a weeaboo,
so we've got weeaboo versus like, I was meos, check the info next to their name,
Kiana is a fitness buff who's looking for a fun way to provide for her family that ideally
makes a lot more money than hairdressing, real, Tiffany is a college student who's looking for
a way to start paying off her student loans but can't seem real, okay hold on we're doing Tiffany,
because that is the most stereotypical you can get, I'm just trying to pay my way through college,
what cute, meoscripts, we love it, what was the point,
oh my god I love this,
I love the style of R, oh my gosh, oh we got an achievement, employee very first come girl,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, five cash 15 minutes though,
uh-huh, okay,
okay,
oh, oh, is she, I mean, what, you want me to send mandatory outfits to the girls,
custom outfits, you need to wear this on stream,
we'll have to release some dirty photo sets for free,
I'm sorry, Emmy has really nice feet, I don't care what anyone says,
I don't like free but we need the exposure, oh my god this is when we release Twitter audios,
so five plus fans, so money fans, we have to collect the new fans she attracted, so do that,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yes, yes, yeah, yes,
uh-huh, I'm sure I don't need to explain what a fetish is to a sick freak like you,
but it's important to, oh my god, I love this game,
but I adore this game,
what, they have like real pie charts about sections, if you will,
this is, I'm sorry, this is actually really cool, sorry,
so if you had a bunch of dudes who were into Black Chicks, that's not going to help
an asian girl at all, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, my love.
When you send a girl to do a photoshoot, I'm going to then interest new fans who match one of
her fetishes, you've said that, you've always seen which fetishes the girl satisfies by checking her
profile, I'll show ya, click her face on the studio bar, her fetishes are listed right here
Uh-huh, and she can have three more to go
Okay, Stony management sim at Joe Bieler sim
Uh
Okay
We'll kick off a show is normal drop her off at the camp studio for a hot minute
Okay, okay
Okay, okay click and hold okay, we can click and hold got it got it got it
Carpal tunnel game. Let's go
But we're not gonna make any the money with only one girl
Oh my god, we're opening auditions
Uh-huh stop this is so
You're not winning any pageants
We got
My god, sorry this game seems so polished
Buildings can have three girls receive cash Wow
This is so shilling the other couldn't be me she says there's I
Recorded the audio of me being like how much does a smaller agency VTuber make in a month?
And then I'm like 12,000 US dollars. I've recorded it. I need to send on to the editor
That's literally me shilling and soon point to click things to go ahead and invest in stuff
Uh-huh
Okay
Okay, yes
I'm not getting any
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, I can do that
The better there are some dope
Big mother black
Okay and get get fooled
I can later to go over some other stuff with you. Okay. Thank you. Thanks. Uh, right. Let's go get a new girl
Yeah
Yes
Okay
Oh my gosh, this is so good. Sorry. I must say this this game is good. This is polished
An accessory
Cash flow from operations. Don't worry. This is the only in the game. Okay
What is that wage? What's she talking about?
Right. Wait, hold on. I'm just gonna do this right now
I think everything's like good volume levels now
I'll just leave it like that
I mean, there's no reason to make a bad game only
That sounded a bit better a bit less intense on the music
Um
Honey knows how to make games have they made anything recently? I was aware of what honey pop is but this game. I'm loving it
Okay
Yes
Oh, I love this
Uh-huh
The higher her style level is the more fans she will attract right kiana's back will hire kiana
But higher talent and style levels do come at a cost and she will usually demand a higher
A kiana retry and she said I need a pay for this wien. Okay. Both the honey pop one and two were well put together
I wonder if they're doing anything new
To take her on board before you go off hiring a total babe
A total babe
You can hover over the music note and little bow icon little bow icon
This fan count here is how many of our existing fans would be interested in her based on her fetishes
Okay, so we've got latina and
We're gonna recruit because she never drinks or smokes, which is really good
But these both frequent smokers
Although she's very good though
No, I
Sweet
I'll do my best. Uh, right. Should we work on getting what fans like this?
I feel like it's like more worth it to get fans
And then send them off
Are we doing speedrun tactics? Right now we're gonna do show
Oh
I don't uh, I need more money
Am I doing correct? I don't know if I'm doing correct right now. I have no idea
Uh, right. What is in this? Oh, we can have a third girl already
Receive two plus cash each time you collect from this. Sure
Automation all locations will all collect resources once every 15 minutes
Ads are I've not got ads unlocked yet
It says promo but it's like hidden out imagine if I just recruited all the girls from the first game
Why is the building wobbling right now? What is this?
Hardware camera quality up web server streaming quality up
Receive two plus fans each time you collect from the photo studio or that might be a big kind of boost
Buildings can have three girls at once
Uh, right. We are gonna send you to get me someone
And then we're gonna put her in there
And collect more money
How do they relax though, I have no idea
Right, we're getting a new girl
Oh
Sarah a guy who oh my god, it's sugar
Uh, frequently smokes and drink. See the she says never on both
I'm tempted. Nikki is a shy nerd girl who started out streaming video games
But quickly realized how much more money she could make by showing off the kids
Zoe's an insufferable millennial who tries a little too hard to be unique. She
Mm-hmm as
Wait
They unironically did the helip. What's that helicopter Apache meme
Sarah is an unbearable weeaboo who thinks she's Japanese and calls herself suki
She's the worst, but they're still kind of hot and weird. That is hilarious. This game is insane
That is hull
No
We have a few girls. It's time to think about training
Being naked on the internet isn't as easy as it sounds you gotta put some effort into that shit
If you drop a girl off your strip club, she can dance to earn talent point
Okay, and if you bring a girl over here to the fashion boutique, she'll earn style points by shopping
Okay
Her talent or style level will go up respectively
Just remember the higher a girl's talent and style level are the higher her hourly rate will be uh-huh
Okay, hold on all locations all collect let's do that receive test. I'm not sure about
Uh
So do we just I don't know what the carry item is. I don't even know where to get an item
We'll do give it a shot
Uh
I'm just farming
I'm not sure how to do this
Is this this is about modeling. Hey, yes 100 right 21st style point
Uh
Yes
I love that
Okay
I'm loving this right what's going on here
Three plus cash when you collect carry an action. Let's do the item thing
Because it told me to do the item thing
Remember to check how you need to pay them before midnight midnight. Oops me who just spent my Steve
No, this is
Okay, okay, okay
Is that what I think is
No way it's got sugar
They really said we've got a Colombian and they gave us the sugar
All activities will be done twice as fast I mean shit
Okay, let's get some money
Money money money
I don't know how to
All right, hold on
Right go go go. Sure. Why not?
Uh, yeah
Oh, whoa, we just made the money
Right, what do we need to do next? It elapsed two minutes each time you click to rush an activity
Elapsed two minutes. It's like good or bad. All occasions will all collect in just a minute
Receive talent
talent
Receive community each time you click. I think this one's the best one to go next camera quality up fans earned from increase
Okay, that's good and that's good. So what 150 to get community hardware and web servers and then think we'll start doing staffing again
Clicking dreams of time
How'd I do and I completely forgot what I was supposed to do
Yeah, yeah, I love that. Yeah. Yeah, right everyone make money make money
I don't think so
Okay, she's not making me a lot of money. I'm gonna have to send her
I
To make money, but I'm doing terrible job. Right. We've got 50. So let's invest in money
Uh
Cash earned from yeah, right. Let's do cash first
And then when we get 50
We go again
Wait, why can't I not go?
Oh, you're too stressed out drats. Okay
Hold on
Right. We need 50 bucks. Wait you too stressed out. Oh, they're both too stressed out. Oh, no
Let's just
focus in
On her making money. Okay invest
Receive two flans and you do the thingy the shoot. Yeah, sure. We'll do both of these is fine
500 is the next upgrade. Okay. Okay. 50. I guess if it's 50 bucks, it's an
Buildings can have three girls at once. Okay, we can want to do capacity
Cloud lightning equals stress watch out strongy. They're closing. They're close to dropping. They better not please
Click three cash every time. Okay, we're gonna invest in the 50s first. I guess
At 50s
All right, maybe we'll do the relaxing spaddy because I kind of need them back earning money
right go
Go for gives that money
Money
Right, go again. Oh, she got me. She got me 30 though. Oh
Wait, hold on
Oh my god, she's giving me the good strongy working these girls like robots for two bucks
Thank you fab
Mathey, I'm not doing that bad. Right receive three push clash cash. Yeah, let's do that one
Uh, and then we'll do community so we can get fans of it better
um
Okay, she's making like 30 bucks every time she goes in I'm here for it
Get more accessories. Sure. And you go
Okay, she's stressed so where you go
Oh, we can invest in a 50 already. Um, all locations will collect receive
Do do the fans and then do capacity then do automation. I think
Completely suppresses the urge to drink that sounds OP
Um
Completely suppresses the urge to smoke. I'm gonna get that
So
When we hire the next girl we will add it to whoever's needs to smoke
Because that sounds really good
Okay invest 58 buildings can have three girls at once. Good
It is uh
The nicotine patch it's us mommy. Yes, little reef one
I'm on it. Okay
Locations. Oh, do their thing. Okay. Next. Let's go into staffing and we'll hire more girls. Let's go
Now that three people can be in a studio at once we shall do that
And
Oh, you're too stressed. That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed. But you I need you
Can we invest no 91
100 straw knee is not just the working girl. But as to would you guys let me pimp you out?
What is that notification say it's fresh out of what?
Oh, no, it's about to be midnight. I'm about to go into debt. I think so if I invest right now, I'm about to go into debt
Uh
Let's show we've not really upgraded the fact your bucket. I like living life on the edge. What are you gonna?
Let's say very quickly make some money
Wait, am I gonna die?
No, no, no, we're gonna be fine. It's nothing personal. It's just business, baby
Nothing gets in between me and my money. Yes. Yes. Yes. Don't worry about it. Uh, we'll be fine. We'll be fine
Uh
No, the wrong one draft. I meant to put them in here because we need to hire a new girl
We need to put one of them in the recruitment
Sorry, I'm dumb
Excuse me, I like the music. I can read that out, right
Oh she be
fashion Aaron style points
each talent
No, okay, we'll do the wine box. So then it doesn't matter who we get from the model agency. We can put items on them
Um, right, let's focus on making some money
Because I don't want to lose my first run because I suck
Yeah, it's a thing. What are the books 13 bucks?
You need to go again for me. We need to get the money
Right, you did fantastic
It's literally me right now though for real for real
She'll only demand half as much pay. Oh my god
I'd I want to go all out on the wine boxes. Right go mix her. She kind of needs fans though
Because she is not right like, who are we going?
I
Whoa 13 hours, but she's like way up here
Ico Ico is looking for a way to fill her days after recently been fired from her job as a university professor for misconduct
Lailani
Moved from the pacific to get away from her strict family and lives by the by her rules. She acts shy, but she knows what she's doing
Pardon me. I just burped
I'm gonna get Ico
And then I'm gonna shove all of the stuff on her
Uh
How do I uh, how do I put items on her? Oh, no, they can only hold one item
How do I put an item on you?
Hold on
Wait, what was her addiction?
Addicted to drinks. Okay. Wait, hold on. Hold on. I've got give me
Okay, so she's not addicted to drinking but she'll smoke a little bit
Uh, okay. Okay. If we can do this the wine box would be perfect in your book
Wait, honey
Cam has the girls from honey tuna. Take Ico the uchi Asian from the game. Ico is a dub
Sarah has a huge huge fan count. Yes, I can do that
Uh, let's
Talent
Does he need talent or am I being crazy? Wait, what did you
What is uh, forgotten what this does Aaron's point cash will
Aaron's more fans per oh, I think it's better to do the cash
Yeah, we're gonna need some money
Yes
Go you're too stressed out. Of course you are. That's completely normal because you can't be a robot
That's fine
Right, you do not make as much as she she makes 34 per
Session if you will
Right, what's the next upgrade so receive five plus cash
Oh, these are 500 though
I mean it implies that this one productivity and accounting are that you are in debt. You still need to pay them to drive
Okay, okay, I'm working on it. I'm working on it. How do I get more smokes? She's just going to singy
Okay
I am trying so hard level. Okay, so it puts them up
52 cash though
Oh every time she pops in
Yeah, that other one does not really make me much money. I wish I had displayed their names. What's your name?
What's your name? Nikki Nikki with the blue hair
Tiffany is free. I may send her to get a new item
Because the girls that don't get stressed don't actually have any bonus items on them
Not too bad. Nikki's too stressed out. That's okay. You're allowed to be stressed
Nikki's gonna need your pops and
He's a cake
Uh, Keanu's too stressed out as well
Oh
I am gonna try and
Just max out money because we're about to have to pay at midnight. We're at 8 30. So I'm playing it safe
We will just do the midnight thing
Sure, I'm just gonna go all out of money for her
Almost yeah, because there's currently unless we speed this up a bit
Oh, and I can get them back and then there can be more than one
Oh, please get to work minus theory again
Fans earned from a photo shoot increase
Wait, these are all full shit related
Should I just do nicotine patch? No
Uh
Sure, let's get this one for no particular reason at all. Hey, Tiffany for no particular reason at all. Here you go
Oh
Wow
Oh, Nikki just does not make me any money. She really doesn't
We're at maximum capacity. Oh god, this game's harder than I thought. Am I gonna lose?
For no particular reason, right? Let's just get her more fans then
Are you gonna be stressed out?
Uh, I feel like yeah, but
What do I kind of want to get the one we're more oh, it's 500 bucks right do 100 bucks investment
as soon as we can
because we're struggling
Nikki you are not going to be doing shows you do not make the same kind of money maximum capacity wait wait until she gets out
You go make fans you do that
This is getting rough
Right 100 bucks. We're almost there
I hope the rest of the girls are not watching this right now
Me and August like that's it. Everyone do this do this. Get out. Get out. Get out. Get out
Uh good, can you like
Get slightly better at anything. I don't mean to be nasty. Nikki, but you are struggling right now
To do anything
Okay, we've got 100 bucks
Accounting receive extra cash
That's two minutes when we rush. So we're gonna do that one next because apparently we're like rushing through the entire day by accident
57 cash, okay, that's good. You can go get a new item to give to the girls
Oh wait, I accidentally put
The boutique all right
I'm not a girl, but I will get out
Strongly working everyone to the bone. I don't know what I'm supposed to do. Am I supposed to manage their stress?
I assume I could just put them all in at the same time
All right, we'll put her to rest
Nikki's now level two
Oh, you're too stressed. That's fine
Uh
You're going straight back in misses 57
Although we can get another girl if we really want us
Receive
Streaming quality, uh-huh girls can carry two items. Yes
That's very good because you need a nicotine patch
Yes
Yes, that's what I wanted to do right
Okay, they're both relaxing so I'll skip time on them relaxing because we need to farm money like no
Do we prepare for a new person coming in with nicotine patch and stuff I think we do
I think we just prepare for a new girl coming in with the smoking and drink situation
You're gonna have to go make some cash because you're doing terrible
Strongly now needs a purple coat
I walk with like a pimp. Was it a walk like a
a real og
I don't know what I'm doing. Can you guys make some money? Oh my gosh, please make some money. I am dying
No sweat. We're about to go in the red again
Why am I so bad? I think they need to get more fans, maybe
Maybe
Yeah, sure you did fine. Oh, we are not gonna make the payroll
335 bucks
I don't know if we can invest in another girl
Oh
My gosh, wait, why is this game so hard? I'm doing something wrong. There's something I'm not picking up on
What am I not picking up on earning an extra 10 bucks? That's fine
Stream call a cash earned by 500. Right. Is that what we're going for?
Uh
Needs more
Overlap every time you send them to the adult store their price goes stop. Is that real?
Ico is expensive time to time is going by too fast as well
Should we do the 100 bucks then?
This is hard
I'm trying
right, let's do
Well, she's about to finish right go again
Oh
Yes, go right. She makes 500. Why do you make 57 bucks?
Because you've got talent times two
But then that puts her base price up. I need to give everyone the piggy bank
I'll do it
The price depends on style and talent not many have I think training the girls is more important than money
Think about how well we are allowed to if the girls had zero experience
Honestly
If I 15 fans
But there's no overlap
Uh maxipum capacity
I don't know
Does shove everyone into the bit club
I'm trying to get more fans in the categories with that other girl and then if we hire someone
That has like same fan base that would probably help out a lot
She's already pretty talented, I don't know. I'm probably gonna regret putting her in there, but
I
Know you you have hardly the output
God they're inside the studio for so long. I'm definitely missing something 57 cash
I cause less than 30 fans does she? Oh
If we're still in the red by midnight, it's over getting them trained is pretty important
Is it fans are getting them trained like this?
I don't know
I'm trying
Okay, listen
Sure, if you say so right 200 fans
I thought this was gonna be a chill game because literally I looked I was gonna play idol manager
She is she gonna end up making the most money
I was gonna end up playing idol manager, but you guys were like that game's actually super duper hard. Don't do that
So I've not done it
I feel like I'm doing something terribly wrong
Girls can carry a third item for 2.5
We'll do the elapsed time one against my better judgment, but she's about to be stressed out
It's too expensive for your current setup
Well, I guess you're just gonna get more fans
Okay, so Ico hardly has any fans
So
Do you want to go get some?
Okay, we made it to 100 bucks. So we're gonna invest. I know we're gonna go in the red
but
I'm needing help
With this zoom in thing. I need the time to go slower
Should have gone for she was way cheaper
She makes 52 cash now, okay, it is I need to send them into
The thing need to get more fans. That's fine. I can deal with that
Yes, go get more fans
Everyone go get more fans. We're trying we're trying out here. Okay
I know we're gonna go into the negative. We were scaling too early
Okay, everyone go get fans go get more fans go
Okay, you're too stressed out. That's fine
And then everyone's getting sent away to make money
Come on come on come on come on
All right, go make money. Okay. She makes 164 now
That was the problem. We needed fans. Okay
That was the problem. I didn't optimize
You're too stressed out. That's perfectly fine
Okay, everyone's getting sent to this little photo shoot everyone's getting sent to the photo shoot
I'm learning we're getting there into the content mates. Everyone do a publicity stunt right now
purposely get banned go on a two-day
Suspension and then come back and then everyone will go nuts for you. Okay, everyone do something out wildly against to us
But not to against to us
I don't make myself clear
Okay, I think I made myself clear everyone get fans. Okay, you hardly get fans when I send you away though
Oh my god a hundred and are you too stressed? Okay, that's understandable. Have a nice day
Oh my god. Okay. We're learning. We're learning
Right you make 81 sure get me 81 the now
Something yeah, someone do something controversial. That's it. Do what damper did get that
Okay, okay, okay, I'm listening to make it easy for you. I put together the promo section, you know the drill
Open up that window for me
This is a list of all the sites. Oh, we can just straight up buy fans. Okay
Bedsitter's bed post. Okay, you're done
Soriety secrets hot chocolate love stop
Each site caters to a specific fetish. So all the new fans gain from that is hilarious. Oh, that's so good
Two so we don't have to wait around for fans to trickle in
This is so good for my way. If you invest in advertising, we'll have more promo opportunities every day. Okay
Okay, I
I am understanding
I'm comprehending right everyone go make money the now
Because we're gonna buy promo
Yes, we're gonna buy promo if it's free and I don't have to send them. Is this dealer? It absolutely is
I'm trying so hard to hit all the categories. Okay. We've got lollipop on the go. We've got penta
We've got
Chocolate right you do 81. Sure. Why not?
right
We have we've got another one for
Teen
Okay
Okay, okay, okay. I'm learning. I'm learning right go get more fans
Right promo. No, wait. I've still not made the money. Wait, hold on. Hold on
Okay, I'm starting to slightly get it right. We don't have any fetish for hot chocolate lover
Do we have the girls that cater to those? Yes, Tiffany is a
Oh, she's also banal
Okay, I'm learning I'm learning
We're at 45 bucks though
Ha we're at 45 bucks already
Hmm should I go all out on money at the moment?
What would be the next one 250 receive 10 plus cash
Four ads will be available. Sure. I'll put it into ad space because if it gets me if it skips the part where they have to go
Oh, you're too stressed. Sorry
If it's oh my god, she makes 180 though
Okay, I think we'll go all out on buying ads
And just try and get the money we are going to go into the negative but that's okay
We working on it there we go what we're looking at negative. Oh see only negative 79 today. Okay. Okay. We're getting there
What does promo look like today?
uh big booty
And glasses are the only two that we can utilize right now
So we have our objective
Done with that
Okay, let's invest like that
Glasses yes, we have two with glasses actually
Okay, okay
so
glasses and that one
And that's all we can do today
For investment wise that way
Sure, we'll get some fancy
Easy peasy, huh? Oh you're too stressed out. Sorry. Sorry
Oh, we are like you doing it. I will take your whole stock of ico
We might need to invest in the chub and chocolate for the new gen moment. Okay. Okay. I hear you. I hear you
Uh, we could maybe do
You're too stressed out. That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed out
What are we looking at for all locations will all click? No, it's fine. Um
Cash earned is increased by 50 percent. Okay, we're gonna go all out on that for now
I think that's the best idea at this point in time
But we are starting to get a lovely
Gross
We are starting to do it. It looks like advertisements are way to go but we will invest in a
Okay, let's hurry up with the spaddy so someone else can get put in as well
And
And then
For making money it's fans modified by their talent value time to make them go into the club
Okay, they have multipliers
Mmm
Nice capacity. I'm just telling her like continually get more fans
Because she's upgrading glasses, which I assume cascades on Ico
I don't really tell her to stream that much
We'll try it. We'll try it. We'll try it. It is going to put up our base price for the girls, but they are doing pretty good right now
Okay, there we go
investment go down
by the cam
Community you receive three plus
What next is the game maybe accounting is next and then capacity and then I will get a new girl because we're at the point
Where not everyone is fitting inside
Sure, why not?
200 bucks 200 bucks two nine seven
Two two eight nine you should get more toys
You would say that wouldn't be a little refling
Oh, we are starting to cascade what Ico though. We're at 300 bucks already. Is there anything we can get?
We can all right, okay, okay, we're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it. We're getting there
It just took me a hot second. Okay
I'm just very dumb
Now I'm gonna put something on nicky because we keep pushing her
I don't know how little or
How much we're gonna go under for debt for the payroll, but we're trying
That's the main thing
Are we even gonna go into debt today 700 wait why 700s?
Why 700
If the girls get those fans has a high talent she'd get more for Ico
Yeah, I was gonna put something on nicky because nicky's getting glasses
For her right now, which is really good
Oh my god, this really is a strategy game
I thought it was gonna be the easy peasy strategy, but nah, they're going for it
I'll see if I can get a comp. Oh, you're too stressed. That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed. Right. No, not nicotine
Girls habits improve. She'll only demand half as much pay. Uh, that's really funny
No
All these are temporary
The piggy bank seems all right though
Oh
Right hold on books
Kiana's actually charging a wee bit
You can calm down here and that's what's up
Wait, hold on. Is it girls?
How do I put a piggy bank on you?
I've already forgotten how to put the piggy bank on hold on
You calm down. Thanks. Stop charging me so much. I know Ico doesn't have a free slot yet
As well as subscriber pillow. Did they get paid while relaxing? What a kind card
Every ever they stream cost you and you're running some of those girls into the ground
Oh, she makes 194. Does she make more than the other girl?
I guess because she's making all the fans in her
Category
Oh, she only makes 140 now. She's the weak link
I
Don't want to level her up. You know what go and get another toy
What's in my inventory I forgot
Keep forgetting right actually already have a wine box and nicotine patch if I wanted someone new
I think I need piggy bank for Ico
Wow, that's rough. Ico is killing us right now
If I can get a piggy bank, I'll have to invest in
Oh, there's actually a few things we could invest in here
We don't have the others yet
2.5 for a third item
Ouch
You are the weakest link goodbye
Yeah, because she isn't leveling up
I know but if I level them up they cost even more per hour
That's currently the problem I'm facing
1.9
I don't want to level them up, but I think I'm gonna have to
Go get some more fans while you're at it
302 cash though
I like the little heels sound
Yeah, she's gone up to 14 you're too stressed. That's fine. That's fine. Everyone's too stressed. Everyone's allowed to be stressed. Okay
Orange stale while shopping in half the time
Sorry, but it's just cat ears. I don't think cat ears are very I don't think that counts
um
Well, we've not done that on someone so
Who's getting in uh
sports
I'll just shovel on here. Okay
Ah
That maybe wasn't the best idea but hey ho
Can you switch items? Yes, I assume so
Okay, she's just gone out to 194. So do we farm fans again?
All right, we don't have that invest what five girls all locations
I think four girls in a building and then we'll do the staff one
I say that as if I'm not running us into the ground right now. Go get more fans
Or maybe I should I should invest in the more fans thing
I don't know what to do
I'll invest in the more fans thing it will put us in debt, which is fine
But
Um
Imagine if we just hoarded piggy banks and gave them all to the girls. I'm needing to shove one on ickel
But I'm like hardly getting the cash
Kiana's stress free but where am I she only makes four
It's six new things right. I know this is bad, but if we get more fans
It'll be worth more and yes, I know we're about to go into insane debt
But that's my choice to be a dumb dumb and puts on debt again
How much in the negative? Okay 200
That's not bad. We took down 200 in the payroll
From that piggy bank manoeuvre
A little bit. How much are you owing? I all pair day
Oh, it doesn't really say per day
Ha ha ha
You're too stressed out. That's okay. That's just very terrible timing
Good we're getting 200 per show. That's good
Uh, you're getting close to 200 per show which again, it's good
What how much do you get per show though?
300 per show don't mind if I do
Don't mind if I do
Sure, uh, we don't have fit do we?
No
Oh, we do have fit okay promo fit go right Tiffany should have more fans
Depends on their work hours
No, no one will be getting a sign-on bonus until they've done their work. Did I make myself clear?
I think I'll go pick up another item because some of the girls don't hold anything
Probably gonna regret it, but go
One two five she makes more than the others
Right are your weakest link. Yeah, you are right go get us a new item
And then Tiffany you hurry up so we can put you on the site. Okay
Go. Okay. Yeah, she makes way more
Okay, okay, we're keen to get in there
I'm like did I just hoard money so I can put three items on the girls
Ico has the stream to make up the cost. See if I can get piggy bank
It's getting thrown on to Ico because she is just
stupendously
I recommend putting them to work 24 hours per day because every moment they're not working is useless stop
I wish I could make a joke right now, but that's hilarious
I'll let you cook again
You did fantastic. You're too stressed out though, which is fine. Um
Receive 20 plus cash each time you collect from the studio. There can be four girls in a building. I'm wondering if that's the best thing to do
Hold on let me cook but in a bad way
I'm gonna invest do that one
Oh wait, that didn't help
Hold on hold on piggy bank. Yes. Okay. We're gonna go all out. We're gonna go all out on
Getting the third item we give that to Ico then we're laughing to the bank because she just cost so much at this point in time
So that's done. Yeah, but we're getting 300 cash for what she does. Okay. We're going all out
We're going all out promo. We don't have these yet. So there's not really a point just yet and doing it
But we are going to try and get 2.5
thousand dollars
I'm enjoying this game so far. Sorry. I like it. I like these kind of funny asking right. What is the negative we're putting?
We can recover. Okay. We can rebuild. I repeat we can rebuild. What is promo today?
I think we have a flat chest. Who's flat Ico? No, you're not
We don't have a flat chest
But we do have a piggy bank so
We can do the s word
Hmm
You're too stressed out. Of course you're too stressed out
Okay, okay, we're going all out. We're gonna get this third item. We're gonna give it to Ico so she can stop draining our supply
Bad luck on ads today. Yes. I'm just gonna go all out on money. I'm gonna save every penny. I think we can do it
I think we can do it as soon as Ico gets that piggy bank. We're laughing because it hardly cost us a runner then
Come on
Come on. Why are these shows taking so long?
I feel like you'd be done after the two-hour mark. I'd be like, oh, I'm exhausted. Come on. Wrap it up everyone. Wrap it up
Give it a shot. Oh, we got a thousand right. We're at a thousand. We just need to do that again a week
Oh, you're too stressed out. Of course you are
Too stressed out right go make some money
Right. Well, we need a thousand more dollars and we're done and we're not at noon yet. So I think we can do it
Come on everyone wait hurry up and relax
Mm-hmm says the endurance streamer. Yeah, they must be rappers
Are they streamed for 12 hours a day? Okay, I'd be exhausted. I don't know how these girls aren't stressed out the wazoo
Okay, go again go again
You can do it right. Hurry up. Hurry up and finish. Yes. Go make some fans
And then go make 300 bucks go
Go go go make cash make cash. We need 500 more
Come on. We need 500 more
You would be exhausted
Where are you?
But there's something to do with some of the de-stressor options being
and
They must be yapers. Yeah, they probably yap for like three hours and like right. Let's get down to business
Oh, come on. We're so close to getting that upgrade
Yes, we're almost there. Come on
Go go go
Right, we did it. We did it. We did it. We did it. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I know this is against what I want, but
there
We've got enough
I would not we're really just shy. It's fine though. It's fine
Right piggy bank time piggy bank time for real for real god. That was 800. Are you fucking serious?
Aiko you cost so much you cost so much money. Aiko you are running us into the ground. Do I make myself clear?
So is she be streamed? Hey
Come on. Her yap is the best though
I want to go get cool. You did fantastic, but you're too stressed rubbish
She makes 300 now. Yeah, definitely need to get them more fans. That's how we're getting like any money
Right one more batch at the camp studio and then
Then we can upgrade to three items. Aiko gets the piggy bank. We can invest in another girl
We can start investing in the promos as well. What are we looking at to do?
Decent the cost are pretty penny though
You keep working the girls to death and everyone but Aiko makes like 75 cents a fan at best. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
Let me cook though. Let me cook slowly. Aiko high quality high cost. Yes
Yes, go make money
Okay invest
item books, okay
you
Stop charging me a ridiculous amount of money
We should just get 18 fans. That's six hours or I can just get money
You're too stressed out. You're allowed to be stressed out
Go make money
Right, so can I now get a fifth girl? I can and four girls to our building
And aesthetics
Training and aesthetics don't do anything
Building and then we'll get new staff about that and then I'll start sending them to the shops to get
Items to get more fans in certain categories wink wink
They took way too long to pick that now her corpus isn't gonna be in debt so it was something
Okay, I can do it. I know what I'm doing wink wink. I do not know what I'm doing
Yes, you're too stressed out. You're allowed to be it's okay
Go make some more fans. I think is oh someone needs to go right go recruit someone
And then we'll invest in some
We've got stuff for that so go invest in that I guess
Invest in a staff spot
All locations will all collect I don't really these kind of seem a bit arbitrary like we don't need it
5,000 a thousand
Maybe a thousand in product abuse seems best now
Second talent really makes 75 cent training correction is needed
I'm trying I'm trying
Oh Nikki has a huge tag. Sorry I keep forgetting
She makes 300 now
I
Don't know if I'm gonna regret that I probably am
Let's get the new girl in I don't know what the result is gonna be but let's get the new girl in
Nadia frequently well, it doesn't matter what they do to de-stress
Sira gets fans though fan count 178
And we do have some crossover with this one, I think sira
Sira's an unbearable weeaboo. I think it's sira that wins. Look at the fan count that she comes with
And we already have the stuff to put on her
uh Nadia
Is a self-described
Russian goddess who used to provide sadistic
Okay, I remember Lidalia
Erin's one cash for each fan she has and she has 66
But if I level up sira, I want to say sira. What was that noise?
Uh-huh
Okay
Um
The premium pass but it only takes an hour what's the downside
Nasty dudes are walking around with
What's like without a little risk though am I right? They can get
You know what they can get a few dudes
Okay, we're gonna level her up go make some money at the moment
And
Okay
Oh my gosh, not real
Oh, she really is a weeb completely right go get some more fans I guess
Oh my gosh, okay. I need to put nicotine
She really goes arigato. Oh
It's a bit cringe for me hen. I have to admit
Ken is now level two talent goods. I'm glad
It goes well
Okay, there we go, but she costs more
All right, what are we looking at today?
That'll be worth it. That's worth it. That's worth the that is worth it as well. Actually
I think we'll do a full investment from
Need her for gen two right now
I don't know. I saw shebe's tweet on her all if you didn't see it. Don't worry. Um
But she doesn't she's unsure what she wants her
Finalized, um
Her 2.0 idea to be
All right, let's get some promo first because from promo is just more fans, which is good. So that's exactly what we're
wanting
Cheeky bit. Oh, I've just closed off the game. Oh, I almost just ruined that run there because I don't know if it auto saves or not
Okay, let's get right into it. We'll do the promo for it. Wait. Actually, we might be able to do it now
chubby Asian glasses and then that other word wink wink
Okay, and then we'll do investments. It all saves each day. Thank goodness because I accidentally clicked also
That could have gone terribly wrong
Okay
You want 300 you're too stressed out, which is perfectly fine. Don't worry about it. You get 300 that's perfectly fine
You did you did sugoi desune
You did so sugoi desune. Don't worry about it
Right invest
I don't want another girl at this point in time
Um elapsed three minutes each time you click
So what all locations no, that's rubbish
It might be hardware or advertisement each fan. Okay. Hmm. That might be worth the you get a receive five fans each time you collect
Wait, no, that's rubbish
It's web servers hardware advertising
Capacity is five grand
Up to six girls can be employed at once
It's either five grand for web servers hardware advertising is 1.5 and maybe advertising
It's the way to do it productivity is important. Am I be am I misunderstanding?
Hmm elapsed three minutes each time you click to rush an activity
Yeah, I'm I'm gonna just take on what you guys say
I'm not gonna doubt for a second that you guys are completely correct in what's going on. Okay
Um
Because this is confusing. I'm sure there's real strats that I could have but I'm being very dumb
Right if you're all done, can we get you more fans? Maybe
No, I'd rather everyone just work right now
You're too stressed out. That's fine
She really said completely. I love her. Sorry. What's your name again?
Sarah. Konnichiwa senpai
It's a boy. There's an a
How'd I do?
Uh, right everyone makes some motherhood cash, right?
Invest
Not six girls at the moment
Maybe that adds promo what we're looking at
I love this game. This is so good fame
I'm gonna send them to all pick up items now
We can invest in items in preparation for the next girl
And again, if I can get piggy banks on these girls, you know, we're laughing to the piggy bank
Okay, okay, I understand you didn't like it
But at least I tried, you know, right everyone's getting put to the shop except for her because she's got the best
Just yeah, go get stuff at the shop, please
Bet that we would be your moneymaker nowadays
Probably right everyone go get items right now
Either we'll get stuff to prepare for a new girl coming in. I just want to make sure yeah, I have no items. Okay. That's fine. I have no items
Okay, let's hurry up these girls so they can pick up some items
Quick quick quick
That joke was a real porker right piggy bank get
Who are we giving it to?
Um, pardon me, sorry
Right, we're giving it to you
Right, okay you are you too stressed out from shopping. Oh my god. So real bestie
Again another piggy bank. Absolutely. Again. I'm not absolutely right. Who doesn't have a piggy bank. Yeah, you don't
Tiffany and
Nikki do not have a piggy bank. So let's just pop them on
So everyone's now just gotten a bit cheaper. That's what we like to hear now. We are gonna go make some money
I think I've just comprehended what the productivity bar is doing
Um possibly
Right go make some money too, please
What else you got?
Please make more money
Time to send them to the spa and swine and dine on this game. It's already halfway done. I think
Tiffany's still level one. Is she actually what a legend
She's doing a level one Elden Ring run right now for real
Right promo. No invest. Let's go
Six different ads sure and then
Oh, we don't I don't want to recruit a new girl just yet
Maybe this one web servers. Let's do web servers
Tiffany's mother became to cross them there herself assume. What does she do? She's 50 50
Okay, now that everyone's leveled up. I am going to purposefully level everyone up and everything
Yeah
Okay, let's do that. Yeah, surely
Because now that everyone's got piggy bank
I think this is one
I don't know sounds like a plan. They can make more money that way. Okay. Okay
Oh
Something's leveled up, but that's okay because we have
Well, we just trying your to stress that that's fine
Yeah, you did so goi desune
We you did kimuchi. I promise you did kimuchi
And promo we don't have anyone to support that yet
Is
Yes, that is it right you get leveled up and we'll get everyone more fans
I don't know if I'm doing it right, but sure go. Oh, you're too stressed. Sorry darlin
Do you run vealers same way you play this game? Absolutely not. I really hope the girls don't feel stressed
We actually did a tweet recently being like we need more clippers, please if you have clipper experience messages
a um
Because I don't want the girls stressing. They just have to send me a link to
What the dealio is?
Okay promo
Okay, that looks good, right and then can you like max out someone's level?
Sure, why not?
You must be able to max out someone's level surely
Surely that's how it works
Right everyone go and get more items like right now
Yeah, oh you're too stressed. That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed
Go get more items like all of you. What would I have? I have nothing great. I need wane. I need
Does I need piggy bank on anyone?
Right, you've got piggy bank piggy bank piggy bank piggy bank. Okay. We need piggy bank and wane and nicotine patch
That's fine
I think it's fine. You could invest in training to make it go fast though
Do I even have enough?
Okay there
I'm starting to get it. I think I misunderstood what they meant by the upgrades. I don't
All right, there's three of you in here
Uh, no
Okay, you're done
No, what?
Right. We've got a wine box
Tiffany's too stressed out. That's okay wine box
Piggy bank for the next girl
Go stream, please because we need money
Go get more fans
So we need a nicotine patch and then we can fully recruit. Oh, that was such a good role
Uh, okay
What do you want more fans? Maybe what are you?
Okay
Maybe level you up Ico's maxed out. Okay. I'm just gonna try and max out everyone now
Surely that's the way to do it surely surely and don't come with surely
Okay, we can recruit a new girl fully so at a thousand bucks we'll recruit a new girl
Hey, I'm gonna max out everyone now this girl it's kind of worth one payout instead as well. Hmm
Possibly
Who where is the room?
We're all split apart in different buildings
Okay, go finish relaxing. You need to go make some money
And then I'll go tell them to all get more fans
Yes, you did quite in a go
Okay, everyone go do a show go again 1.6. Okay, we're getting there. We've levelled everyone up
Uh, let's just fully level you up for the shiz and giggles pro. Oh wait. No, I should have sent her to get a new girl
Oh
That's fine. It's fine. We're getting your girls up very shortly
I'll send whoever finishes up first
It's a good idea to keep someone low skilled to just run errands. Okay. Okay
Maybe messed up slightly but hey, that's me automation. Maybe worth the money now that there's multiple buildings going on
Go get a new girl, please
You did fantastic give you a little weeb you
We are in the negative but only because of the old stuff
That's just more of just keep them shopping or finding new girls. Okay
You're almost done. Uh promo what we're looking at today
Oh, we don't have enough yet. Hold on. Sorry. Sorry. I'm getting greedy
We don't have enough yet
Right hurry up and get the six girls so I can start sending her on stuff
I've got two in spaddy
Go make more money, please
Okay, yes you are. Oh, sorry
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. We're getting there. We're getting there. We're getting like a thousand every show now
Which is not bad at all nothing to be snuffed at nothing to be snuffed at
There are
Right, you've got the girl you do not make barely enough
I might just send you to go get I am
Lilian. Hello. Sorry. We're taking Lilian. He he
We're getting Lilian
I don't care Rene Rene escaped her hometown and moving out to the mid-mest
Fulfill her dream of becoming an actress. She's working her way up. You've got to start somewhere steady on Nora
Nora's a badass who grew up on the streets slinging rock to get oh
That's not what I thought it meant. I understand what that means now
She's out of the game, but Ren ain't gonna pay itself
Lilian is a goth out brat who hangs out at the mall and does pretty much anything her parents disapprove of just annoying teen tattoos
and you come
So she smokes
She smokes so now she doesn't now she's half the price
And then yeah, you're not worth anything yet. So we're gonna send you to get an item
I'm gonna send you to get more fans
She she she she
We love shadow wizard money gang. We love Lilian in this house
Let's get some moneys
And let's get some new fans going
We don't have anyone that does that we do have someone that does that
Can I you're too stressed out? That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed. Okay
All right, go get some more fans. I'm just gonna farm fans for around
We are making three thousand per go. Yeah, no
What is it with the cake fans honestly?
We can put any random item on Lilian at least because she doesn't drink at all
A thousand
Ike was fully maxed out. I guess we would just form fans. Give us a thousand because
What we putting in Lilian? I mean if we're basing her after me
Uh go get another item for us
Uh, oh no, this isn't that good
Who doesn't what do you have? Okay, we'll give you the water bowl
Oh, she's so happy. She's oh wow, this is amazing. Thank you
As long as you're happy. I'm happy. She okay, everyone's getting there's three in the full shoot right now
One point four one point three. Okay. I think we've cracked the system. It just took me a hot second to understand
It just took me an uno momento if you will one point four
Okay, we did it we did it we did it we did it
Uh promo we're not interested in that. I don't want a seventh girl just yet
I would take
Capacity for five K then five. Oh, maybe five K on web servers
Ooh, that's a juicy number
Mmm, Tiffany's too stressed out. You're allowed to be stressed out
I think
Oh, I don't know
You know what I'm gonna do ads and then I'll do web servers, then I'll do capacity. How about that?
Please kill me. Oh
Are you okay darling? Why would you see such a thing?
I guess I'll just send you on earth. Okay, if we're gonna get a new girl coming in
We'll grab piggy bank in preparation of the new girl
I'm
One point five one
Higher a manager you already have six girls automation would be a time saver. Okay. Okay. What's automation?
Productivity
Accounting since the profits are so who usually take minutes to collect
Lilene super edgy and honey pop to issue. She needs less stress take the plug on
Right next to automation 500. Okay, we can do that easy peasy. Let me squeeze that's so quick
That's so quick
Come on, this is taking forever
Oh
If there's money inside you can time stomp it oops
Is that gonna okay doing it in the background
Uh maximum capacity go get more fans, I guess
I'm not really sure what to do with her that much
500 book each
She gets a thousand I feel like she could probably get more sure she had more fans
Next thing please
She only makes 500
Going some more fans right subscribe instantly earn 50 of the fans that would be earned from a photo shoot after performing
Whoa, that seems OP
That seems OP is but what have I got we need a nicotine patch and then we can get a new girl if we want
It's OP. Okay, hold on
We might be taken
Hi, okay, hold on. Let's put on Nikki
Okay, okay
She's gonna get fans every time she streams that's fantastic. Oh my gosh. She is she's gonna gain fans in the background
That's OP
Right, we're gonna we've got 5000 so we'll upgrade the studio next so we get even more money
It was a while since I've seen this game. I have no idea how old it is. I just remember everyone being like, oh my gosh
Did you see the new game?
1.4. Let's go
What do you make you do not make that much in comparison to your pals, I'll just send you at the shop
Okay promo no not promo. We'll do promo next actually. I just realized oh should we do capacity?
We'll do capacity next but we'll do promo first if that makes sense
Because it is just free fans
Here we go, I think maybe just buy oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa that went up in price
That went up in price
Yeah
That went up in price indeed I just send her to that
That went up in price
All right, we really need capacity before we get the seventh girl
This game is eight years old. Yeah. Yeah
1.7
You're too stressed that's fine
What do we do glasses?
I'll take because nicky is going crazy
That subscribe pillow is OP
Oh, it's promo
Sure more fans for aiko
He's a cake
1.6 sure
me when stroning
2014 was a decade ago old man emoji. She makes 1.2 now
Sure, we need to max out on the thing uh
Nicotine, okay, we can get a new girl without any issues now half the price
But we wouldn't even be able to yeah, that's what I didn't want
At max capacity
You're so real for that
Please kill me
Payroll process three grand. You've just stolen the thing from us. That was good. Yeah, you did sequoie disney, please
How'd I do fantastic? Oh, she's making so much though per show
right, we'll do
capacity staffing
next, okay
Don't start talking about the ages of things the first strike came out in 2001
Hey
I thought it was fake that strike five thing. I think you guys were trolling me to be honest
I was like, okay, you've got me. I believe do but I think it's actually real
Hold up a minute. I think it's real anything else. Yes, please more money. Go just go
She does not make as much
just
How about go recruit a girl and we'll get her when she's ready
2.7
Yeah
You've stolen that from me strong complain about paying a 1% wagery. You've yanked it. How dare you?
2000 this is okay, we're gonna get the five in a building we can do it. I believe I believe
2.4
Don't mind if I do
All right productivity come on
Capacity and then staffing is 2.5
You do not make as much as the others though
You hardly make that much fans either. I'm just better at buying fans
With the ads on twitter ever lie surely not
Play red dead redemption to actually want to play it
Um
I've never played it before but everyone went crazy when it came out and apparently you can role play on it like gta servers
people like role play on gta servers
To stress out that's understandable. Have a nice day
Right our new girl who will we pick bailey asian and chubby and they called her bailey and she's chubby
She caters to chubby and she's called bailey. Okay, you're done
bailey was a conservative yoga instructor until recently when she discovered her true nature and frankly she kind of a freak
Um
Brooke is a wife mother in business woman who seeks out attention online from young men because her boring husband leaves her drier than a desert
Oh my gosh, okay. Lilian looks good to me. Lilian moved in from the pacific to get away from our strict family
She's asian and flat-chested. Yes. She never drinks so that is good. We can put an item on her
Right, so she is now waiting
To get stuff done which is fine
Uh, we'll send her off to get new items because if we can get another subscriber pillow that would be good
Um
Oh wait, can I get her now? Oh, I can I can already get her. Oh, we've got one more slot left
Right, you never drink so we don't need to give you wine
half price
No smoking. We're about to get you an item though. Actually, I might send you in for an item as well
We're doing every flanks
We're gonna win totally wink wink. We're gonna win
I
Might actually recommend the other viola girls play this because it seems like it takes like two hours per run
Seriously, right. I'm going to try and get the last girl. I didn't realize how close to 71 days we were
right invest in who glasses
We're going to invest in uh nicky because she's so good
I'd just invest in it random and hope it pays off. It's a boy disney
That's because promo is promo
Yes, fantastic go again. Oh my god. She's 3000 per shot now
No, it's a new day. I missed it drat
1000 really isn't like good. I might just keep telling her to go get more fans
Oh
Oh, no, she makes more than the other girl though
Piece of cake go again go again thing, please
okay
Hickey bank
We just need a nicotine patch and we can get the last girl just like that
Go make some fans
Oh wait, we didn't get a nicotine patch this time
Oh
Let's do sheepsters who can even pick up
you
Oh, wow, she actually has two free slots
awesome
What does she need she needs another tag that we can capitalize on about you
You can just take on anything as well. Okay, right. We're gonna send you back into the shop
There's no five in the camp studio, which is hilarious
I'm not sure you're gonna get the diamond trophy. I'm not even sure we're gonna get the last recruit
It costs 10,000 to pick up someone now
Literally 10,000 to get the last girl
That's insane
I mean, I think we can do it but
Nikki is coming in clutch right now with this subscribe pillow is insane
Absolutely insane go again
Motel time
Possibly
We can't even pick up the money that fast like it's taken so long
So we can't even like make the time go by faster
Any point in doing for sure
Oh
Maybe I do need to invest in the money thing
Ha it seems like such a waste though, right water nikkies assets
Glasses big and water
glasses water
big and glasses
no
huh
I'm sure just gonna make some more fancy right pro right invest in the freaking money thing
So we can actually upgrade the team because it's not even letting us upgrade the dang team
Sure
Neckle ears or bandage. We just do bandage
Oh
Wow someone should draw of running the casting couch
Steady on that's funny
Right, can I grab all this money?
You're too stressed out right well unstressed yourself right now
Go go go please give me ten thousand right now right you make three thousand that's so good
I think we can get the girl we're literally on the 21st day. We're about to get the last freaking girl
Well, we're on the 18th day my pardon
That's a nicotine patch. Oh, did I mess up right?
What did I do?
You're full you're full you're full full full. Oh, you can still actually get an item
Even after all this time
Right, someone's getting sent to go and pick up a new girl. I don't know who it is. I don't care who it is
Hopefully we can have someone that's a non-smoker
But go go get a new girl
What else you got
Staffing go
We're max on staffing
go
We're doing it. That's where the income upgrade comes in. Yes
I'm starting to understand why they offered it because it made no sense. I was like, yeah collect money faster
But it's because you can't upgrade
The dang thing you did fantastic. Go make some fans
Oh
Come on promo
Sure, let's just buy a few things
Because it's worth
Go again you make 3000. Oh my gosh
What did I want to invest in already forgot it
Forgot it. Okay. Nice English
50,000 wait, that isn't even the last upgrade
That is insane that is in the last upgrade
Okay
No, we went into the negative
4000 right last person
Please marlina
Candice candies nuts. Thank you
Who
1000 fans she brings on but you've already levelled up completely
Marlina is a brazilian bombshell who basically cost her life on the rebellion look. She's very confident and extremely narcissistic
Marlina bosom stop candies nuts. Candice is kind of an earhead who just goes along with whatever people say. She's a professional
with a big
Candice is a non-smoker
Oh, she's yeah. Okay. Candice is the best because we can put a slot on her
Enjoy a full staff of eight girls. Let's go
So give her wine. She's now half price
Go get items for yours. Oh, you're too stressed. That's fine
Okay
Now we can just focus on doing generic upgrades like having more girls in the studio at one time
3000 3000 you're too stressed. That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed
They come to brazil
Brick with a one key fans out of nowhere honestly
I
It's day 19
It looks like we will get our productivity upgrade, which is what I want to see
You did sagoy, doesn't it as always you did fantastic if you give girls. Mm-hmm. They can go to the
How do I get girls strongy? Uh, uh, uh, I have terrible news
I don't know how because I'm not a guy and I don't know what it's like to try and get a girl
Right everyone go pick up items because I think
2.4 really isn't like good
Okay, subscribe pillow. Sorry subscribe pillows to op you're too stressed out. That's fine, right
Invest capacity now we can have more girls at once doing the thing, you know
None am done
Go work
Everyone go work
If mommy's the one stressing me I would enjoy it. Isn't that clearly you just got a hiring agency
I mean you could if you want to do it, right promo
2000s for promo
But you're getting like 300 at a time. Whoa, that's wait. Hold on. I picked up a pillow
Go
Yeah, everyone's now full so no one needs to go to the shop again. Oh, I just closed my game again
No one needs to go to the shop
Again, so we're wasting our time being in the shop right now. I'm not even kidding
Go sure why not and go
Another subscribe pillow so op I'll just grab it right go get some fans go work
Oh, you need fans as well
I just grabbed subscriber pillows. It's fine
Second has a free slot does she oh she does let's go
Thank you. I didn't know us. Okay. No one has a free slot now. We're good to go
Everyone just makes some fucking money
Hey
And then we can invest in this picking up money thing because it's getting in the way
It's getting in the way clout for
Look, it doesn't matter just be yourself. I had that workspace exactly
If you have to change
Then is it true love if you're not being yourself you're too stressed out
Okay, we're at 10 000 promo. Do we bother with promo?
Just buy it just just buy. Okay. Just buy it
Okay, we're not going off yet
Just buy all the promo because it's fans and it means I don't have to send them to the cast and oh
I've done it again. Stop clicking off your good figure right work work
Everyone go work
Do I make myself clear?
Work work work. Oh, we're at max capacity
Okay, go wait who makes more you make more
Hold on hold on i'm gonna invest in the max capacity 25 000
I really i'm not gonna waste it. I'll just get her to get more fans
Whoever is that lower one look at all those subscribers. They got 10 000 subscribers. Let's go
Oh, they got 9.7 000 subscribers. They got more subscribers than me and it's like they've been at it for 21 days
They're cheating
Uh go make some more fans
Okay, we're on the last day I think
Go go
I don't know if we can do the
Invest in anything more really
Maybe this I don't send anyone on photo shoots though. So it's not really a point
I'll do accounting for now because they're grabbing so much money. It's like hard
Right you hardly make nothing so let's not waste our time you make 4k
Maybe we can get the upgrade you did fantastic, but you're too stressed. That's okay
I'm getting the silver trophy aw ye
Hi, I love how she does that
5 000
Well, I just buy it in promo maybe
I
Have no idea what to do at this point. I mean I've got everyone and people are just rotating between like
5 000 that's good. We're just rotating between like
I don't really make a lot. I feel like the girls make a bit more than you
How the fuck is goth not making money? I tell everything I owe for her
I've not leveled them all up at any point. Um, Candice is too stressed. That's fine
Might as well
Oh
Right, let's go optimize for fans. I've not maxed my investments because I suck
Okay, we've got 25 let's buy capacity so everyone can be making money
It doesn't matter if they're low or high everyone can make money
That's the focus
Go make money
So I can pay everyone off because I actually need to pay for everyone's thing
I think we're about to end
Does the game let you continue to play or you're too stressed
I'll just keep the money on hand or do I get like points for fan amount maybe possibly
Go oh you're too stressed
Go make money go go go. Oh, it's the last day today. Okay
It's the last day today. I don't think we can do anything in particular
You'd have to do a new run bronze five silver 10 25 fans is
platinum
50 and diamond is a hundred fucking cute fans are you serious?
So I guess just buy promo
And then we can hit what?
Oh, we're not gonna reach platinum. There's no way
There's no way we're reaching platinum
I can't see it
10k maybe
Sure
Just spending the money
Kitsune game and thank you for becoming a member
And the membership membership streams are gonna go crazy out the wazoon two weeks time
I'm going to do back-to-back membership streams. I'm gonna do daily membership streams and public streams
Please don't think I've forgotten you if you're unable to member. Please don't worry. It's not it's honestly not a big deal with me at all
um
I always got free content coming out. I actually have a patreon audio
Early access for youtube. I don't know if I can upload it yet. It's me sitting on the mic ASMR
But because I was like squatting over it
I was getting out of breath and I'm like I can't upload it
Like I've got two shorts that I want to upload but I don't want to do it until the warning's gone
In case I get a warning for it because I really do not want to strike. I do not want to break my streaming streak
Um, I would be so upset and mad at myself if I did
We've been thoroughly drained into literally you thought my stamina was good for like bruvs you're done for
Oh man, thank you for the 10 gifted memberships. Congrats to whoever caught them with your face
Um, the emotes are coming. I'm waiting on mercedes emotes next
Um, let's just buy the promo. I don't know how many fans it's going to get me but oh 18k
Fans we could have got 25k, but we can't do it
Unless what 64 fans that's not going to cut it. Are you joking?
Right, we've got 300 more fans we can buy new emotes. Yes new emotes are on the way for everyone
Emmy and aces new emotes have already been uploaded
They should be lurking in the shadows. They actually have a few more emotes slots to go
So they can get more if they so desire
8k for that. Wow
Um, I don't need emotes when I have what png that wasn't a png heart. Well
Um
Uh-oh
Okay, go are you too stressed?
Right, we've done it
We finished our run. This is the last night. We ended with 20 000 that's not horrific. It could have been worse
It could have been worse
Could have been worse
Um
Could have been worse, but I'll just leave the money on hand. I don't want to end when we can't pay them
So we'll just shove them back in here
png that wasn't a png. Wow
Time flies you're having fun, doesn't it? That was two hours to play that. That's fun. That was like a perfect stream game for one run
Oh god, complete a game session without dropping below five cigarettes or drinks. Oh
diligent degeneracy
Hmm
Minutes rushed
Oh
Lifetime revenue two eight seven. We made quarter of a million most popular tiffani least popular
Latina most popular was tattoos. We only hired like one tattoo isn't lily in the only tattooer
I didn't realize how much I was covering up of the downstream. Yeah, I maybe should have sat here in the middle, but
Uh, yeah, we lily in
Be our only thing
Most expensive. Yeah, I call you were so expensive. Erin girl was kiana. Sorry kiana
Even though I can see it in the top corner question mark
That's awful, I love it
Stop that's so silly. I love that
Wait, we've got point. What's this tokens are used to unlock outfit new hairstyle and wardrobe via the title screen
Ah, we were so close to gold. We could have been snack bang in the middle
P good peeler allegations
Yeah
Or and earn some more wardrobe tokens, okay
Personally, I don't really care mostly because I'm not real later. Oh
Lillian wait, how'd that continue? Yeah continue
I just want to keep playing it because I just want to see how long it takes me to get everything unlocked
What's next?
Immersion broken
I just want to see like
Haven't seen all right. I want to finish all the investments off really quickly. Let's just buy everything in sight
Get through a strong a real no high scoring. Oh, I'm not that good at the game
Oh, she's too stressed
Let's try and get all the upgrades and then I'll redirect
Um, I assume she be is live question mark
Maybe unlock some outfits on the title screen. Yes, we'll see what outfits are on the title screen
a
Let's get all investments first
Not promo sorry investments. Uh, it doesn't really matter what one now. We're not against the clock
Oh, she's live. She be went live before you. I have been outplayed. It was that late to stream what the heck
Okay, she be caught in bum is live for any hero members that are lurking in the shadows. Please don't worry
She started early today. Ooh, she was feeling it
Yes
Uh
I guess if we buy promo we can get more fans and we'll get more money
Oh, lily and make seven k now
Per show
Finished
Why do you sound like cream?
What can we get just everything?
Uh, let's do advertising
next
Maximum capacity. Oh, you're stress free. Sure. Go get some fans in
What are you gonna do after stream? Um, today I am going to a cafe with my dad
I had to cancel it yesterday because I went to sleep. Um, I was not very well all yesterday
What do you mean pushing yourself daily is a terror? Wait, why he cost 13 000 to get that? I'm not buying them anymore
No, we're not going to meet cafe. No, lol
um
Or just doing a cafe today nice and chill. I kind of said to him like I can't be
Streaming and then like doing stuff every single day. So the plan is every other day. We're gonna try and do something
um
Because I was like hyper stressed out yesterday like I was watched back some of the stream and I was like really unhappy
I was like, why did I even stream like that's so silly
I just felt like dumb that I pushed myself to do it
But I'm glad I didn't like take a day off or anything because that would annoyed me true
True AF dempa. How are you doing?
Candice is too stressed out
She is
And
What's too stressed out? That's fine. You're allowed to be stressed out. It's only human nature. I'm only human
Buildings can have eight girls in them. Yeah, I think I'm gonna do that because that's hilarious eight key
Nine key not bad
How long is your dad gonna stay?
We actually so I thought it was three weeks. It's not it's already two weeks. Your dedication is inspiring
Thank you. It's the autism
You want to make six thousand?
Lilian's too stressed out. Okay, you can go chill. Don't worry about it. You chill out
Oh, wait, I just realized I have to pay them still
Eeps forgot to pay them. Okay, maybe we'll do promo
Anything shove on anyone
Doesn't matter who
The more fans the better
Keep telling you to take it easy. I will eventually well I go jumped from five thousand to eight thousand per go
Hold on get some more fans
Everyone's going to the photo shoot because what the heck? Why was that so much?
How much do you make you too stressed out? What do you she makes fans every time she goes so
Payroll processed. I didn't go in the negative. Let's go
You're too stressed out
Mmm
Right, let's make if you're not at ten thousand per show then you're getting shoved into the photo studio
Ten thousand you make three thousand you make nothing. Please don't do that. That's how she must have lost something
I don't know what oh you play getcha
Your dad's a favorite food, uh, no idea
Please kill me
You're so real for them
Um, we made chicken last night, but I'm having steak today
Okay, she makes ten thousand so you can go in
You have my permission to go do a show
um
You do not make ten thousand yet
Are we
Are we making nothing? I'm gonna have to upgrade her
Nine thousand go you make twelve thousand
These girls are making that mula you make eight thousand. Maybe I need to
Do that. Yeah, I think I need to upgrade them. Why isn't he kicking? He is he's kicking for me. I've never eaten so good
I've never washed so good as well
It's like I'm actually having daily showers a Christmas miracle right everyone's going to the club
As well. Everyone's getting fans. Everyone's going to the club
I will do glasses because uh nicky's glasses and she's currently our biggest money maker
Okay, ten thousand that's good
Eight thousand right that there
Did slow cook more I did marinate a chicken with them
He I like have never bought ziploc bags to marinate chicken before but I really enjoyed it
So I'll probably be doing it on this on my own when it goes away. You have rubbish fans
Your fans hate you what's going on here the pheromones it's ogre
So any work in the girls like
Ten thousand right you're allowed to go you're too stressed. What are you you're ten thousand you're allowed to go
And I'll send them to the studio to get a few more fans as well
So no more coins to be I've actually had normal movements as well. I know that's so gross to talk about but it's true
Serious is maxed out. Well, do the
All right, you're too stressed
Okay, our income charge is gonna go up but
Eight thousand not enough go make some more fans
Regular bread honestly, I've never eaten so properly. I've never washed daily in like so long
I'm gonna very quickly go grab a can of cola. I will be right back. I don't even
I
Hope you didn't hear that
I just went out to get a can of cola. Did you hear it?
You didn't thank god
He just goes inside
And I didn't hear it. Yep tweeting right now. No stop
Bless them. We didn't realize I was finished
Okay, ten thousand right you're getting a bit better. We're gonna put your style up though
We didn't hear nothing except you yelling
Just uh stop stop
Stop no talking no toky toky
30 000 oh my goodness
Right, we're gonna invest in
capacity maybe
Right max capacity goods
So everyone can go to work if we want
Which is good
You weren't kidding about the fool. Hey, can he help it cannot for the life of him help it
I'm like don't don't say my name. Don't say my name. Don't say my name. Don't say my name
Don't say my name. I don't know how many times I said I've said a stream
4 a.m. 6 a.m. Don't say anything. Don't do anything. Don't phone anyone. Don't like
bro
That's why I'm like I can't I can't have them on stream not even for the teehee funny ha ha. I can't I genuinely cannot
No name got dropped. Thank you for checking. I appreciate it
So basically your POV was
That was your POV she was brining along double two
I can't tell you if I heard or not. Mm-hmm
He's innocent. He taught me
Finish pure path. But I don't worry. He's not actually in trouble. He understands. It's silence. You screaming. Don't say my name
Um, I thought you're screaming because no cola. That's hilarious
Maybe her name is chicken. You've got me
You're too stressed out. That's okay
Right. We have a lot of money
Let's do
this one
Full shoot. Sure. Why not advertisements maxed out? Oh, mate. Wow. Maybe we should advertise maxed out advertisement and just bought
Fans for that 25k
Get him used to calling you strong. Well, it's because he doesn't need to in any other context
Yes, I can do that. Give it a shot. Should have muted. I will definitely mute every time I leave the room now because yeah
I thought that was gonna be okay. Okay. Oh, no, I just oh, she's not leveled up enough to utilize any of that
Maybe the name is ah your POV scream reminded me of starfox 64 death
fox
Is it bad?
Did I do you have butchers headphones? No, I do not actually
All locations will all collect
That's the hardware. Why not? We're almost fully maxed out and then we'll just level everyone up
Once you get used to stormy, it's gonna be a problem cause we're strong all the time going forward
No, I mean if her name is ah, then I think I
Can't even a few things start a name with that. Oh be Flynn. That's funny. You can't say that out loud
That's
God nicky makes 18 ago that subscriber pillow is so OP
Can I
Oh
Yeah, I can so who you've got it you've got it you've got it
Maybe better to get a subscriber pillow on her
Cause she doesn't
You're so real for that
Maybe I'll send her to get a subscriber pillow
Oh
Right 50k let's buy a promo because why not if it's literally a thousand fans in the category nicky is big
Nungas and glasses
Glasses and big nungas. No. Oh, yes, actually we'll buy that because that's good for her
12k
Nicky started as a as a girl who got fans for I know she prints money because all the fans are rightfully hard
Do you need to be concerned about cost right now you could replace piggy bank or something else
I'd rather not risk it like I just want to do the full upgrade run just to see what it's like
What else you got?
Right no, we're not gonna buy max max max
Buy we're just gonna buy it because we can
And then we'll send all the girls to the
Clubs to get fully leveled up and then I think it
I can't air for your life, but I can do that to your back. I just said it on
Dean
Stony calls. Have you been hypnotized in humans again?
Bruh someone made a meme and they were like how's world domination going and it was like absolutely terrible. Thank you for asking
No subscriber pillow, right
No point then. Okay, maybe we won't do that
Rubbish, I don't want it
You should check out every girl prego. I'm gonna check out Lillian
hairstyle bright baby
Stop
She's a mall girl
Cup size B wait 110
Fan count. She's addicted to the cigarettes
But she's healthy. That's the main thing
Oh, you're waiting
She tried to hit me I mean
The world dominates you instead. Honestly. Stony. How are you so good at ASMR? I just really enjoy it
I think I absolutely fantastic creative outlet for we've been for real for real
I just find it really good creative outlet and thoroughly enjoy it
14k 17k wow, uh, who are you bubble gum? Candice you are catching up on nicky
Hmm
Literally strong except she smokes. I was thinking about my alternative outfit. Whoa nicky's 22k
I was thinking about my alternative outfit being
You know goth version of me
A bit more how I am
Um, which was an interesting concept, right? What do you want to do?
We'll just go level you up because you're not really doing
Hypno dad cuddles
You forget the name honestly
Gothic cuddles I'm down for a gothic version. Um, what else you got? That's
Not my priority. The girls is all outfits are my priority. Um and a couple of months
Um
Yep, I'm going. All right. Yep. I'm going. I love that. Stop it. You're making me fall in love
That's still not maxed
That is insane that that's not maxed out yet
New short drops like no or is your tube one crazy?
Not for me. Um, I already had a short drop
It was called like explosion veiler and it's me talking about the sonic heroes. Oh, I see
Someone was like plagiarism and I'm like, no motherfucker. That's called influence. You can be influenced by things
Oh my god, we are making the moolah though
What bye is anything I can invest in
Oh, jeez. These are getting expensive. Oh brother
Oh, you're too stressed
Inspired by no, I was because I sent it on to
Hey the guy and he was like, yeah, sure I can make something like this and it's completely different
You can hear the influence if you listen to the song, but it's completely different
We've been influenced by a moment
Too stressed
You really do not make much money. Do you darling?
No little leon he do not make much money all
It's a dark hair
I don't know. I quite like I quite like the purple and black
um
For an all idea. So, you know, hold out your breath. I might I might have a little thing that looks a bit more like
Like I have a choice
More like into the cult don't you want to try the motel at least one? No, I don't want any of them to get in trouble
Okay, I'll send I'll send a
Lily into the motel at the end once we've unlocked everything. I'll send her at the end
She's got one fourth the fans of your top earners and it's not like you already have fans that are delicious flat chest
Uh
Just use a hmm. Do we have one we don't
Right, I'll keep sending her away
Okay, let's
Okay max out so many quarter of a million and 120 believes it
Shawnee calls will cut we're in a
Sure thing
But I would but it would give you an achievement. Oh, does that actually right. I'll send lily lily at the end
Oh, wait, maybe it doesn't count if it's not gameplay because this is like over time in the game
I heard for the third time the story about in the short
I
Invest what I need 250 and 120. Okay, we can get 120 right great now
Oh, I got it. I just got it no more 120 max. Okay last one quarter of a million
Yes
Right you go what you to do you're to go pick up uh
Johnny or a rubber if you're british
Okay
Are you winning son? Yeah
And we're getting through it
Everybody let's get too
Sure
We need quarter of a million and then we'll send everyone away to get leveled up fully and then we'll send
Lillian away to have some fun
This beat is sick. I wanted to come right and you just
Yes, I'm going
Yeah, this subscriber pillow thing is going wild as well
They're doing it. They're doing it. They're getting me all the money
Okay
Lady Gaga not the disc is thick
I'm on it. I love this game. Sorry. I'm absolutely adoring this game to hymen
Okay to the kingdom high heavens come this is so good
Like I have a choice. Uh, you do that's why you consent matters
Go work work work work. No, no, no work before I have to do the payroll right invest boom
Are you serious
Are you serious right now?
Are you serious half a million?
Together last upgrade
If you could choose a design any of the girls have for a future den
I think I want to make she be gay to
She seems to have an interest in it and if she doesn't want to submit for that
So, um, if the girls sign on for another year, uh, we
Vealer offer them a free alternative outfit
Um, they just tell us what they want and we'll get it concepted and if they're happy with it
We pay for it and all that type thing
Um, so if she picks something else that isn't gairu, I'd love to offer gairu if she signed on for another year because
It goes that
Oh, you're too stressed out completely
Um
It come
Sorry, I'm trying to
Like all play this game, but it's not working in my head
Time to grind. Yes
um, I'm currently
Hyper focused on Azura getting moved out because I think once she moves out she will have so much more time
to be able to
Really hone her craft because uh, Azura's got it. She just needs enabled and I hope her donathan has come
It's on the 21st of august
So don't be shy to you know, keep a little little five dollars back. That would be very kind of you even
Small things add up very quickly. So, uh, please do if you are
um
Written for the girls. Um, I would absolutely love to see Azura's donathan go off the wazoo
Um
You make absolutely nothing go get some fans
It's too stressed. That's fine
Um, she did the gairu classmate roleplay. Yes, we we redirected inter and her per head was coming off her neck
I do not know how to use the booth stuff
so, um
What was that half a million that better be the last one because that's insane
Azura the goat for real for real. Yes. Um
Like she's interested in doing youtube roleplays like just to put up stuff for free like more content basically
But due to our living situation, I mean, you know where it's like it's busy houses are busy. That's just how it is. Um
So we're gonna try and get her moved up
Dullahan gairu bunny stop. That's actually quite funny
Not in a mean way though
You just like plop it on to be honest over the top layer
What what?
What was the context of that?
Hydration check
We're at 30,000 fans. I don't know how you're supposed to speed run this and what in 21 days
Okay, we're more fans
We're almost there
Optimization literally, I think it must be you need more fans, but I'm like being a twat and not understanding
Be not afraid. Oh my god. Her headless
Thing was absolutely her hilarious
Be not afraid
Oh, we're almost there, but we're about to have to pay her wages
We'll do
Early subscribe pillow leveling the girl's styles, etc. Yeah
I would say this is such a well polished game. What was the end of eight years ago? I like this
I enjoy this
I'm having a good time. I hope you're having you
An enjoyable place or even though it wasn't the most oh come on. Are you serious a million?
Right, everyone's getting shoved to get more fans because this is getting outrageous. Go get more fans. Everyone
Right, let everyone level up
As well. We're leveling up everyone and they're all getting more fans because that's ridiculous
Maxed out maxed out. So go get more fans maxed out maxed out. So go get more fans
We'll finish this
What's next maxed out. Oh, you're too stressed
Okay, everyone's getting thrown in here to get more fans because oh my goodness
You're not maxed out you you're too stressed
Maxed out that's fine maxed out maxed out fans. That's fine
Never seen this game before but I heard about it. Yeah, I just I remember everyone going crazy for it
Like I used to watch a lot of let's play you beat it
Not be tubers youtubers at the time and everyone was like, oh my god
This game's so outrageous and I was like look how far we as a society have come
Because it's really not that outrageous and all honesty
I feel like we're
Oh my god, we're so desensitized as a site
Oh, would someone please think of society at large
I should have shopping levels them up. So the girls are gonna cost a little bit more doing this but
At the end of the day
Doesn't matter since we're in end
Pardon me. Sorry. I cannot stop burping away right now
Wow
Why not
People freaked out about the first mass effect pearl culture little did they know how society has turned out now
It's ogre right fans maxed out maxed out fans
Everyone's getting leveled up against their will maxed out right do the club
What else you got right you're maxed out go get fans
Just two in the club maxed out style go go maxed out club go to club go to club. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Speaking of games any new any news on the game. It's most likely delayed to august unfortunately
Now please be nice to me
It was the first time I've ever done anything like that the fact that it's even still gonna come out as a christmas miracle
Um, uh, it's very likely delayed until august. Um
It was my fault because of the way I did the art commission
So
I am not like it's absolutely nothing to do with the
Development team or anything it I am the problem
I'm the problem. I promise you I'm the problem
Um
We can wait. Yes, it's also a free game. So, you know kind of be too mad at me
Uh
Uh new class of one name was an instant any chance it could be on schedule when it releases. What's oh nine
I don't know what that is
Okay, lilians completely maxed out
Maxed out maxed out fans
Max is everyone maxed
Five five
Everyone's maxed once she's finished. We're done. Yay. Oh, we need that
Sure, so once she's done
I'm just generating fans for everyone, I guess
Classable name extremely me me me me vn. That's really funny. Okay. If you guys want me to play it
She likes about the yab game. Oh, no
What does that mean?
How ominous the yab game right how is her
She makes
I think we just spam fans for a little bit
She be played it has she all right, I'll watch her play it and I'll see if it's something for me because
Everyone's getting fans
Right go makes. Oh, you're too stressed. I was gonna go make some money
Just for us
Everyone's all stressed the way
Okay, 17k not bad. What do you make now? They're a key
Not bad not bad
Too stressed. That's fine
19. Okay. It's I mean it could be better in my opinion. This is me
All right, let's hurry up and get all these girls un-relaxing so they can make us some money
Okay money money
What was diamond how many fans was diamond?
Okay, now everyone's just coming away
100 key fans, that's pretty insane
I'm all done
How much is it for promo?
Oh my god, right that's the rule as a head fan wise numbers
But that was so
To do the ones with the pillows or get like little add up the ones with the subscriber pillows will add up
Oh, don't don't forget to like and subscribe to the live stream. Oh
Real streamer by the way
I need to subscriber pillow clearly because I keep forgetting to fricking see it
Wait that she be streamed got private. It's possible. The girls are having to kind of
Be cautious
Okay, uh promo. Let's just buy this thing. Oh
Shilking purchase eight ads in a single day
Shilking
Mmm
Sub to your amp-patreon
Thank you
There'll be an early access coming out after the stream possibly if I don't go right to sleep
I might not I'm not sure yet. I haven't decided yet
Please
Yep, I'm going
Okay, we're at 50k subscribers for the girls
At one month in we're at 50k subscribers. Not bad at all
Very good very good
Sure
Promo
I did not have enough money for this
50k that's insane 50k for one k
Are you too stressed?
And
I don't think so
She private it think because she came on hinge and the human was scared to get in a strike
She's not on a warning though Azura
Emmy and myself are on a warning
So she would actually receive a warning unless she's not told me she's got a warning. She even
Do you have a warning?
Too stressed out have a spuddy
47 grand she makes here
We'll just get a hundred key fans and then we'll send Lillian to the motel and we're done
Um, I got a warning for an audio of me
Actually, it was because I had the audacity to breathe in the mic. I uploaded an audio called clapping without my hands and
YouTube time stamped where I went wrong
What got the warning for and it was when I breathed in the ear of the mic
It wasn't the actual content of the
the
Video if you will
It was because I breathed in the mic
And the time stamped it to when I was in the mic like hey
Yeah, so I might actually be cheeky and upload it again and cut it out at the end section
Um, because that's what the problem was
Please kill me
Okay promo
Just buy it all
50 69 subscribers at all according to plan
It's funny that the actual clapping was okay. I know it's redonkulous 51,000
Holy moly 51,000
58,000
Oh
Yeah, you have 20 key fans
100 fans per photo shoot. I don't know if that's worth it though. I think I'm better just farming
Advertisements
Uh, no, leave it to me if you say so
If you say so over 9,000 on youtube something
Um, like I have I have two shorts
I want to upload but I'm too scared to do it until that warning's gone
But the warning goes away august like 20th, so it's gonna be takes so long
Because one of them is about ear licking but there's no breathing in it
And I think it looks okay if there's no breathing
Yep, I'm going
Okay promo, uh, just buy anything
Everyone get to work and yeah august I think august
12th or something is when it goes away. I can't remember but it's in august
It's a bit harsh for a warning. Yeah in last 98 well a warning isn't a strike
So it's actually more preferred to get a warning because if I got a strike it meant I couldn't stream for an entire week
Um, which that would have that would have upset me far more than
anything else
Can't wait for the orwell stream tinfoil hat. Oh, yeah pure tinfoil hat. I'm not even kidding
Um, it is a bit of a reading simulator, but don't worry. I'll do the reading
I'll do all of that jazz so you don't have to think
um
I played it many a year ago now
So I don't actually and I never fit it. I never got the correct ending in the game
So we're gonna try and get it together. You guys might be able to figure it out before I can
Um
But yes
Anything else more work 51 000. Let's go
I will promo uh chubby
A week without money mommy. I don't want to a imagine a week without money money
I said it the wrong way, but I know what I was trying to say. Okay. Me
At least just rest up
They probably don't want mode schools to the make I think you're looking
I don't know if I think is breathing with ear licking at the moment. Um
It's rather strange what's going on. Um
Rather strange indeed. I wish they would just come out and be like hey, you can't do this anymore
But youtube's was like ASMR is like the top 10 searches
and
So obviously they probably don't want to be like publicly coming out with like oh we
Have fun it by the way
Just need to find the new ASMR mail. Well, I've ordered the denpa
Uh
Mould shall we call it? If you know what I'm saying denpa did a very egregious audio
Okay, which made me laugh more so
Are we at a thousand? Hey everyone's at a thousand! It was a thousand for for the diamond, right?
Oh
The chill bro, you got the ace. Yes, I got the ace
Um, I also am getting another prop
Um for a stream and also the 10 key stream
I think it was 100k
What is a denpa denpa is a fellow vtuber
Um, and I collabed with her on the alien collab that's on my channel
Two out of six isolure confirmed. Yeah, I sorry, but um, he's actually so smart. I'm legit copy and pasting her strats
Denpa cooked with that one
At denpa literally
I'm sorry. I suppose youtube doesn't have more competitors for some of their weird occurrences
So it's been tried. What's her name?
Uh, is it it's not frivolous folks. What's that other asmr?
uh
Gibi
Asmr
Attempted it and it didn't work
It
Because
You need people you can't have free users on it, but it's still like didn't work at the end of the day, which is such a shame
How much oh, but you get so many fans for it though
There was a youtube for asmr. I wish
They realized if they had ads
um
If they had asmr friendly ads like people would be more likely to run ads like at this point in time
YouTube force ads at the start and end of videos
It never used to be like that, but now it is like that which is a shame
100k reach. Okay. Is that it's done. Is that what the diamond was?
Shubby flat chested put all my stonks in there
It's also expensive af to host. Yeah, literally
I don't know if uh another site could be right raised up like that like youtube have a monopoly
Oh
It is a very I love listening to soft asmr playlist and then being blasted by a trucker
Yeah, like I don't know how on earth they come out and be like, yeah asmr is in the top 10 searches
But haven't cracked that if they had acceptable
levels of
You are really lagging behind why?
Oh, she doesn't have a third thing to bounce off of
To make another youtube you would need a time machine. Yeah, like the competition is so hard like
I think rumble is probably the only
It's not even a competitor. Oh, no, I just put no, I didn't want you in the hotel
No, it's supposed to be her. Right. I'm putting her in the hotel now
Lilithin Lilithin is going in the hotel. Uh
We will we're gonna let you have some ciggies. Okay, you're gonna need ciggies after this, but take that way. Okay
So now she's got a piggy bank
Uh, she needs that. Okay, and then this too
Man that meet and greets going wild for her. Oh, she's in the photo shoot right now
I love it. Okay
We've never done this before wink wink. We're we're gonna send her. I guess if you a little you utilize the sleazy motel
You could potentially oh, she just said we say
Okay, go 60k in one hour. Yep. I'm going. Oh, yeah, that definitely seems worth it
Whoa, we're running a little low on cigarettes and booze. We should really take care of that ASAP
A lot of these cam girls like to smoke and drink. We haven't unlocked this part of this tutorial
A girl who smokes and drinks a lot isn't going to get us stressed out from doing activities
But if you run out of cigs or drinks, she's gonna start to get real stressed out real quick
Okay, so if it looks like we're running low you need to have somebody run to the store and stock up
This is the liquor store. Oh my gosh. Wait
We didn't oh
I must have like I must have remembered from the fuck I used to watch that you need to maintain this
That is hilarious
So it takes only 10 cigarettes what?
Per run
That's gonna get out of hand so quickly and then actual well, we made a million though
Yeah, I'm going
That's crazy
Oh fantastic needs to get full efficiency liquor IV drip. So we're still in this tutorial. No, we did it. We did it
Oh, there's a pie chart. Oh tattoos is winning
Chubby
Latina's the smallest
Oh, it like tells you who's like doing that as well. Oh, okay. Okay. Wait, so
Chubby fit
Uh, that one
Okay
Yeah, you can definitely optimize the heck out of this
Okay. Yeah, I'm starting to understand goth solo carry. I'm telling you goth is winning. He's still having this though
Well, I think we did it
Uh, I think we're we're done. So
We've gotten what we can total fan count like I don't think we need to do anything
That was fantastic. I've really enjoyed that game
Hold on. Let me let me pop my background music on and then mute the game. So it's not annoying
Uh, right. Let's see if sheepsters is live so I can redirect into her
Please don't be in a membership stream. Please don't be in a membership stream
Uh, right customization redirect
And she's playing elden ring. Let's go. I can redirect into her
Is she for a cd? No, she's put shields on her chest. That is hilarious
Uh, the goth will say something like I don't want to take the lead and letting the other girls be ahead of the agency
Hold on a minute. Is it gonna be a goth girlfriend of vealer too?
Uh, vealer to the vealer ring. That is hilarious. Let me write that down
It only took you roughly 10 more days to reach the 100k if you didn't want to probably get the gold medal
No goth girl need a slim girlfriend too. Well next week we're drawing your suggestions on ms paint
So I hope you're ready for that craziness
um
That was such a fun game. Okay. So tomorrow is orwell
And then the day after is the vealer collab. I've got balutroll
But that's actually getting swapped out for another stream because I am watching yumi plus's concert
That's right. Yumi plus have a concert and I'm getting paid and I get to watch a concert
I'd rather have goth than slime
Well, I'm gonna be a goth. I think my alt's probably gonna goth up by me
Um, I'm gonna keep the hair the same, but we're gonna I'll get myself a concept that does something else
But yes, uh, we get to do vealer to also known as doki doki panic in japan
Um
Right, I will end stream gonna be directing to shibi. Thank you so so much for hanging out
If you didn't know I have a new short out. Don't be shy to watch it
cost cost a pretty penny penny to
Get made so
Yeah
Oh, the concert sense fun. Yeah, we're gonna react to it. Um, I don't think I'm allowed to play it on stream
But I'm like reacting to it as it occurs. So
Um, that's gonna be fun. Yeah, the sonic hero is my newest short
Don't be shy to watch it wink wink and nudge nudge. You know what while I'm here
I'm gonna be a cheeky shit and just directly link it to you
If I if I can hold on
Hold on. Oh god, is that what I sound like?
I sound rough honestly
Anyway, I share it with you there you go
That's my newest short if you want to check it out the girls have new shorts coming out
I will tell you when the new shorts are coming out because I am the one who normally puts them up
Thank you so much for letting me play such a goofy and crazy game that I honestly would recommend that if you're into those kind of games
That was so fun
Um
Take a good rest. Yeah
Uh, it's just my voice that needs rest. It's so annoying. Thank you for stream. No, thank you for stream
Thank you for being so nice to me and let me play such a goofy games
Honestly, what do you mean? I'm not chasing each of her trends. I can't believe it
She says as she plays the fruit game next week. Yeah next week streams are very nintendo oriented. Normally
I you know, I ain't like that. I ain't repping nintendo like that. But you know
Now go get your pumpkin spice lie. I've literally never had a starbucks
Thanks again for streaming
she be
I'm strongy she beats the bunny one
I call you I call you you try to fix your mistake
strongy cut-outs
She be cotton bum because she's got a tail and she's a rabbit and she has tail
on her bum
Oh great. Don't even get one
I don't know for some reason everyone's like, oh starbucks is so good and this and that and I'm like, I've never had one
I never had the desire
Okay, right. I'm gonna redirect into she be please say hi
Don't be afraid to watch someone who actually knows how to play elden ring unlike me. However
Who cannot play elden ring for the life of me and basically sends you guys to save me. You're corrupting her memory
She be cuttle bum. Honestly. She be cuddly, you know
Okay, well, I don't know I tried to mash them together
She be can carry mommy too. Honestly
I'd believe it. I'm trying to call your bum
Um, but just thank you so so much. I will see you goofy givers tomorrow for some tinfoil hat time
I hope you're ready for some tinfoil in okay. Uh, make sure you get a little bit tinfoil in your head
I'll put up the reefling that has tinfoil on his head because I love it
Um, I will see you goofy givers tomorrow and as always, please pucker your lips because
Um
Yeah, thank you so so much. I'll see you tomorrow and please have a fantastic morning evening and afternoon
Uh, I'm gonna go pass out and then I'm gonna go to a cafe and I have no idea what I'm gonna order because I've never been to the cafe
I'll see you tomorrow. Okay. Bye. Bye. Say hi to she be for me. Bye. Bye. We flash